thanks to brilliant for helping support
this episode
hey crazies you've probably heard of
white dwarves black dwarves and red
dwarfs they're all types of stars or at
least the remnants of stars but there
are also these strange objects out there
called Brown dwarfs they're a little big
for a planet but a little small for a
star
so which category do they fall into
planets or stars are they actually Brown
what are they made of here's everything
you need to know about brand Dwarfs
thank you
full disclosure Brown dwarves are a
relatively new object of interest for
astronomers they were first hypothesized
in 1962 but we didn't discover one until
1988 and that wasn't confirmed until
1995.
so the study of brown dwarves is only
like 10 years old uh what I would do
that math again 2023 minus 1995 borrow
the one borrow the one oh God that was
28 years ago still though it's still
very recent for astronomy we discovered
black holes first
not only are brown dwarves very dim and
very small most of the light they're
emitting is in the infrared range
thankfully humans are really good at
solving problems
when we want to our infrared telescopes
have allowed us to find over 3 000 Brown
dwarves this image was taken with the
very large telescope in Chile in 2004 is
it orbiting that white star right there
no that's the brown dwarf then what's
the reddish brown thing in exoplanet
orbiting the brown dwarf
this is the first picture ever taken of
an exoplanet we had to overexpose the
image to see the exoplanets so the brown
dwarf looks White so they're actually
Brown well no
stars come in many colors and we can
sort them by surface temperature you'll
find Brown dwarves over here below the
red Dwarfs they're like subred Dwarfs of
course Brown isn't dark red it's dark
orange it would have made more sense to
call them Crimson Dwarfs but I don't get
to name things okay don't at me
these Brown dwarves would be mostly a
deep red color but depending on how you
see color it might come across a bit
magenta that's just the really hot ones
though the cooler ones would actually be
black only becoming visible due to
reflection like planets and they
wouldn't be much larger than a planet
either the largest planet in our solar
system is Jupiter it's about 11 Earths
across and contains almost 318 Earth's
worth of mass but if you add any more
mass to Jupiter it wouldn't get much
bigger it would just get denser so the
next time you hear about some exoplanet
that has the mass of 10 Jupiters yeah
that looks like this all objects in this
Mass range have roughly the same volume
Brown dwarves started about 13 Jupiter
masses and go up to about 80 Jupiter
masses but they're all about the same
size
we don't see any dramatic size
differences until you start looking at
actual Stars our brown dwarf stars no
they're sub Stars you mean like planets
also know
on the mass scale they're sandwiched
between planets and stars they're like
the cosmic middle child properties of
both but belonging to neither
classification is difficult work but we
do eventually figure the shirt out did I
hear someone say shirt no I I said shirt
science Asylum merch is always available
just like this awesome we need better
nonsense shirt Link in the doobly-doo
unbelievable
stars have an incredible amount of mass
I mean our sun has a mass of 333 000
Earths that's a lot of mass without
nuclear fusion Stars would collapse in
on themselves inward gravity raises the
temperature of the Stellar core the
fusion from that core provides an
outward counter Force to balance it but
the less mass of the star the lower the
gravity which means the lower the
temperature which means less outward
force from Fusion so lower Mass Stars
find equilibrium at a smaller size but
there's a limit
long-term sustained hydrogen Fusion
isn't possible below a certain
temperature somewhere around 1.6 million
Kelvin which sure is incredibly hot by
human standards but for some perspective
our own Sun's core is 10 times hotter
than that
anyway a core temperature of 1.6 million
Kelvin corresponds to a surface
temperature of about two or three
thousand Kelvin and a mass of about
eight percent our own Sun's mass that's
equivalent to the 80 Jupiters we
mentioned earlier all objects Above This
limit are considered stars and can be
plotted on an HR diagram for anyone new
to these diagrams they're nothing fancy
it's just brightness graphed against
surface temperature AKA surface color
our sun is Right smack in the middle
it's a small white star aside from
allowing our existence it's fairly
unremarkable it's currently in a region
of this graph called the main sequence
All Stars in this region are primarily
fueled by sustained hydrogen fusion and
they'll be here for most of their lives
but if we look at lower Mass Stars we
can see they're dimmer and cooler
eventually we get down to the red dwarfs
they're the coolest Stars they could sit
on the main sequence for trillions of
years
round dwarves are below that
if we go cooler than red dwarfs we step
off the main sequence none of the
objects down here can sustain hydrogen
Fusion at least long term brown dwarfs
are essentially failed Stars you mean
like Jupiter absolutely not I'm so tired
of this myth yes Jupiter is incredibly
massive it contains half the mass
orbiting the Sun but don't let anyone
convince you it's a failed star Jupiter
is not a failed star Brown to dwarfs are
failed Stars Jupiter is definitely a
planet the distinction at low masses
might be vague but Jupiter is nowhere
near that boundary
while the upper Bound for brown dwarves
is clearly defined by hydrogen Fusion
the lower bound is a bit undecided oh
man do I really want to bring up this
internet discourse again okay the
official definition for all astronomical
words is decided by the international
astronomical Union or iau they've been
around since 1919 but they Rose to
infamy in 2006 because of the Pluto
decision
we're not going to get into that today
that decision was for the lower bound on
what it means to be a planet we're
looking for the upper bound the iau has
a definition for this too but it's messy
at best it's just a placeholder it was
never meant to be the final answer so
let's start by taking a look at how
stars and planets form
it all begins as a giant cloud of cold
gas and dust both planets and stars will
form from this Cloud but in very
different ways stars form quickly from
the gas and dust itself usually near the
center of the cloud this consumes the
vast majority of the Cloud's Mass all
the leftovers form into small rocks
first those rocks then vary gradually
combine to form things like planets it
takes hundreds of millions of years
longer even gas giants like Jupiter form
this way there's a rocky core somewhere
in there that's the distinction I think
makes the most sense Brown dwarfs should
be defined as objects that form like
stars but aren't massive enough to
become Stars if it forms like a planet
then it's a planet simple distinct and
clear unfortunately we don't have direct
access to formation history without a
time machine and the last time I used
one of those things went very badly we
don't even know if each brown dwarf
formed in the star system we found it in
or if it formed by itself and was
captured later or if it was ejected from
some other star system so while my
preference makes the most sense
theoretically it's probably not that
useful to astronomers I'm guessing
that's why the iau definition hasn't
been updated since the mid-oughts or as
the Brits would apparently say the
mid-notties
anyway let's go through that iau
definition
item number one objects with true masses
below the limiting mass for
thermonuclear Fusion of deuterium
currently calculated to be 13 Jupiter
masses for objects of solar metallicity
that orbit stars or Stellar remnants are
planets no matter how they formed
jargon alert jargon alert jargon alert
I'm gonna explain it calm down
deuterium is just the fancy name for
heavy hydrogen that's hydrogen with an
extra Neutron fusing deuterium is a lot
easier because it requires one less step
to be clear Fusion always requires that
we overcome the natural repulsion of
atomic nuclei that can be done either
with ungodly temperatures or through
Quantum tunneling ideally both but with
regular hydrogen that's still not enough
to make it stick we also need a weak
interaction that turns one of the
protons into a neutron otherwise they'll
just push themselves apart again
deuterium doesn't require that extra
weak interaction so it fuses at a lower
temperature temperatures you might find
in a sub Stellar object like brown
dwarfs side note technically deuterium
Fusion happens in All Stars before they
get to the main sequence you know before
they're hot enough for hydrogen Fusion
Brown dwarfs just don't ever make it to
the main sequence end of side note
alright back to the working definition
item number one says objects below 13
Jupiter masses are definitely planets
because they can't fuse deuterium item
number two says any substellar objects
above 13 Jupiter masses are definitely
Brown to wharfs it doesn't matter how or
where the object formed how is that
message sure it sounds simple and clean
until you try to categorize objects say
you've got two objects with a mass of I
don't know 20 Jupiters by the iau
definition these are both clearly Brown
dwarfs but then we look a little closer
and notice quite a few differences maybe
this one has a rocky core and behaves
more like a gas giant planet some brown
dwarf Spectra match up quite well with
gas giants but maybe this other one
behaves more like a star it's gas or
plasma all the way down in that case
calling them both Brown dwarves doesn't
really tell us much about them the only
thing they have in common is their Mass
it could just be that brown dwarf is too
broad a category to be useful these
objects actually span three spectral
classes on the HR diagram LT and Y the
l-class dwarves are the hottest so
they're mostly plasma the t-class
dwarves are a little cooler so they'd
likely be a mix of plasma and gas the
y-class dwarves are the coolest so
they'd be mostly gas assuming they all
form like stars they'll all start the
same way as a protostar they'll fuse
deuterium into helium during the initial
collapse but that deuterium Supply will
run out after several million years or
so after that it will collapse further
in an attempt to become a star but alas
there's not enough Mass
mechanical forces can halt the collapse
before it gets hot enough kinda like gas
giants the Ronda Wharf will eventually
settle and its appearance will depend on
its temperature with such a low mass and
no Fusion to speak of these objects are
Immortal full-blown stars become black
holes neutron stars or white dwarfs they
end Estella remnants Brown dwarfs will
be brown dwarfs forever
forever
well unless they get eaten by a more
massive object at some point during
their lives if left to their own devices
though they will cool off over time so
the spectral class depends on more than
just Mass each y-class dwarf might be
young with a lower Mass or it could be
old with a higher Mass we have to
measure the mass separately to know for
sure some of them are so cold that
there's talk of adding a fourth spectral
class z-class dwarfs but that's a
problem for data-driven astronomers
we'll let them figure that one out in
simplest terms Brown dwarfs are just sub
Stellar objects too cool to have any
long-term Fusion reactions but hot
enough that there might be a few
short-term ones if the brown to wharf is
still fresh enough to shine it might
appear a deep red color but its thermal
Spectrum will actually peak in the
infrared we've been able to find
thousands of these objects so far and
thanks to some citizen science thousands
more have been identified for a review
even jwst is on the job now in the end
though Brown dewarf might just be a
temporary name I mean classification is
one of my favorite parts of science but
it's difficult to do us humans we need
to split reality into metaphorical boxes
to understand it but the universe
resists true reality has no lines No
Boundaries it just is
and until next time remember it's okay
to be a little crazy
if you want to understand reality a bit
better brilliant.org is a great way to
do just that YouTube may be interactive
through the comments section especially
on my channel but if you really want to
understand this stuff you need to do it
yourself
brilliant has thousands of interactive
lessons on many different topics from
the fundamentals of science all the way
up to advanced mathematics and they add
new content monthly you might pop over
there to check out their astrophysics
course but once you're there you'll have
access to their entire library of
courses you can even learn practical
skills like how to make neural networks
or do data science Brilliance content is
interactive providing feedback and
helping you understand the why and I'm a
huge fan of why questions
so if you want to try brilliant for free
for 30 days visit brilliant.org science
Asylum or click the link in the
description below the first 200 of you
will get 20 off Brilliance annual
premium subscription it'll also let
brilliant know you heard about them from
me which helps out the channel
many of you pointed out the complex
nature of Schrodinger's equation sure as
long as the time component is a complex
exponential the solutions will be
wave-like but that motion is in the
complex plane it's not real when you
take the complex Square to get
probability density the wave motion
disappears anyway thanks for watching